good
morning i guess here ladies and
gentlemen
my name is on the slides you can call me
slava
because probably most of you can't
pronounce it anyway
and i'm here today to speak about my
experience
or our experience uh if i speak about
myself and the team
uh building the optimizing compiler
for the art so uh
and of course i will be also talking a
little bit about v8
because a lot of us dart people come
from the
v8 team originally and we are all
standing on the shoulders of giants who
did a small talk
and self and so on but i will not be
talking about that
because i was too small and was not
allowed to participate
so uh yeah
what we were trying to do with dart is
basically to repeat the v8 success in
making javascript
a fast language and so we also wanted to
make a fast
virtual machine for dart and if you take
some measure of the success then it
probably would be a v8 benchmark
suit score which i drew on this slide
and the most interesting part of that
curve
is in the middle where there is a big
jump that's
when the crankshaft which is a
adaptive compilation pipeline for
javascript
for v8 was introduced and
the evolution of the performance didn't
stop there is just that the
v8 benchmark suit stopped to exist there
and became an octane
so i don't have a way to continue this
curve to the present
but it's still going up and up and up to
the clouds
so uh the start of this curve might seem
uninspiring
but actually when the 8 was released it
showed on the v8 benchmark suite 10 or
20x
speed up compared to the existing uh
nav vms of that time
so it's a good start so what's actually
the problem with
optimizing dynamic languages like
javascript or dart because dart is also
dynamically typed language
so the problem is is very simple
actually
the programmer writes something that
looks very simple
but machine wants to execute something
that looks very complicated
and the runtime system has to walk a
long and complicated path to get there
so and the reason why this path is so
complicated
it's very simple because the runtime
system does not know where it's going
like there is a property where is this
property go there go there go there
walk walk panic arrive
and the idea that you immediately can
see
is once you arrive to the destination
and know where it is
maybe next time you can take a shortcut
and go directly there
it's a very simple idea but it actually
underlines everything that the
people optimizing dynamic languages do
and so i like to say that the optimizing
compilation is the art of finding these
shortcuts and taking them
well there are all the problems that you
have with dynamically typed languages
is they can be divided into three
categories
one is the problem of finding the most
efficient representation for your values
or objects that will be memory efficient
and also
execution efficient so that you can
quickly perform operations with it
there is a problem of resolution because
everything is laid bound
so you need to find a way to quickly
resolve at least on the second try
properties methods and so on and
there is a problem of redundancy if you
resolved the same thing twice
can you reduce the resolution that you
did first time
i will be mostly talking about the last
two things
because that's what the optimizing
compiler deals with
uh the problem representation is a
problem that you have to solve when you
design your runtime system
okay so i will be mostly talking about
property accesses because that's what
the programs do the excess properties
and in the program it looks like this
very small dot
but it's actually a very fat operation
because
it has to solve or answer two questions
it has to look at the object and
understand what kind of object is there
and then it has to find the property on
this object
and understand where the property is
located and then load this property
or execute a method and so on it's all
proper taxes essentially
so here you might say okay we want to
take a shortcut
so one once we did it once can we just
catch the relation between
the what and where
and the answer is yes you can cache
that's called inline caching that's what
small talk people came up with long time
ago
and that's what majority of the vms i
would say that
are used in production now are using
like even the java vm which is not
operating with a
dynamic language is still using inline
caching to speed up the calls
through the interfaces for example
because interface
resolution the resolution of the
interface methods is roughly
a dynamically binding
okay so but for javascript there is
another issue here
is that the objects they have no shape
so you cannot easily cache the relation
between the shape of the object and the
place of the property because the
objects are just
these clouds of evaporated property
properties basically and and
you need to find a way to see the shape
behind this cloud
and the approach that you can be using
here is
brilliant and simple you just
observe the evolution of the object that
has been built
basically you start with an empty object
and then when you add the property x to
it
you have an object with a property x and
if you add another property you have an
object with x and y
if you had a third property
it's it's a different shape and because
there should be many
functional programmers here i have a
good way to explain it to you
instead of using the mutable dictionary
you split it into two parts
you take the immutable structure
that describes which properties you have
or which keys you have in your
dictionary and you have the mutable
structure that actually stores the
values
and then you connect all the immutable
structures like an empty structure
structure with x a structure with x and
y structure with x that
with the transitions like from an empty
one if you had the property x you get
the structure which contains
x if you add y to that you get the
structure x y
that's why this way you have
sharing of the shapes between
dictionaries that contain values
and so you can use it to quickly
understand
what kind of shape your shapeless cloud
actually has
okay but you can actually generalize
that past the simple idea
for example if you add a function to it
to your object
you can actually think that it's a
method being added to the
class so you can promote this from the
value stored on the object to the value
to a method stored in the class itself
to and that will allow you to speed up
method calls
uh or inline them you can track the
types of elements in the arrays and
represent this arrays in the most
efficient way possible
you can even track type track types of
fields like for example the
x can contain only doubles or x and y
both contain only doubles and so on
and as you can see it's a very powerful
technique
but it's also very complex and it
affects everything that you have in your
vm and you have to design
from ground up for example if you are
trying to concatenate several arrays
your runtime system that performs actual
concatenation
should not try to add elements one by
one to the resulting array but instead
from the start derive the most efficient
representation
for the backing store of theirs array
first and then copy the elements
so it's really pervasive fortunately
dart
does not need that well at least doesn't
need the whole thing
because dart objects are not shapeless
clouds
so when we started working on dart that
was
the decision from the start that we
don't want this hundred thousands
well thousands lines of code in the vm
that tried just to derive
the uh information about the structure
of the object
that the programmer could provide and
it's both beneficial for the vm
and for the programmer because he can
see the structure of the code
and have the methods and so on okay so
all i told you before is useless
oh no not useful at least or
can be useful but not useful immediately
okay it doesn't matter
so let's return to this fat black dot
so how do you organize inventions caches
in the vm in
dart vm oh very simple actually you just
take this
fat dot and attach a small cache to it a
table
basically with two fields one that
contains the receiver
that the fed got observed well the
property lookup observed
and it maps it to the method that you're
going to actually need to execute to get
the property
because the dart is just it has getters
and setters for properties
and loading normal properties can be
also expressed as executing getter and
setter
just with a fixed offset in memory and
so on
and uh it's actually very simple if the
table is empty you go to runtime to
populate it with the current
or if the the none of the cached entries
match
you just go to runtime and populate this
table
okay in v8 it's actually different and i
was also looking for a way to express it
in a good way
and i found it so the inline caches in
v8 they look like big noses so
well because i'm in the us apparently
nobody recognizes what this is
it actually looks like this in in us
so that's a power outlet in europe looks
like that
reminder so they stuff
you generate this outlets in your code
and then you can plug different
stuff into these outlets so the plug
contains the fastpass so it can check
some assumptions like
i see two integers then i can quickly
add them and return
if it can handle it just goes to the
run time and the runtime can handle
everything
the mighty runtime so here is a little
bit of assembly code
i really wanted to put some assembly
code that's the only sliders assembly
code
so uh so the the power outlet itself is
just a call
that uh like call instruction with the
address to call
and this address can be changed you
basically just patch this code as you
as you go to plug different things into
this outlet
uh and the things you plug is the small
snippets of machine code the check and
assumption like here it compares
the hidden class to some hidden class if
it is not equal the expectation is
wrong then you go to runtime to handle
this otherwise you just
load the property from a fixed offset in
the object and you return
simple okay and you can have many
different power outlets as i said but
sooner or later you arrive to the
problem because
uh though if the only thing that you
have is an inline cache then everything
looks at an inline cache stop
and if you have this simple system full
of ic
and you want to specialize something you
just say okay i will just hand write an
assembly
stop for that and do that and you end up
with a special steps for concatenating
string special stuff for pushing
stuff into a race and so on and so forth
computing dates i don't know
whatever you want and this is a problem
because you can write all them by hand
so on so forth very boring and error
prone
and it doesn't actually solve another
problem
so here you can do two observations so
inline caches in v8 they really were
originally the stuff that came
like only thing that v8 had when it was
released were inline caches essentially
to optimize the code
and they were really designed to provide
as detailed overhead as possible once
you
connect outlet in the stop there is only
overhead of the call
and that's it basically and some checks
and in the rtm they are very slow
if you look there is a table there is
basically it does a linear search inside
the table not even like binary search or
hash table
and that's because the dart vm from the
start was
using the inline cache is only to
provide type feedback while v8 was using
inline caches to provide performance
and what is this type feedback i am
talking about here i will tell you a
little bit later
but the important word on this slide is
locally
each inline cache acts independently
from each other in line cache
so they don't exchange information so
you can end up
with two inline caches checking the same
stuff right one after another
and that's a problem so that's how the
compilation pipeline of the v8
looked like back in the day you just
take the source you get ast from that
then you put it into compiler and the
compiler
puts a lot of ics into that and in one
pass it meets the native code done
now the inline caches they do the magic
and speed up the execution
and you do quick node.js i don't know
whatever
so uh and as i said the online caches
they
improve performance only locally so how
to solve this issue
with only local improvements well if one
compiler is not enough you add another
compiler
to the picture and the problem solves
itself
this compiler is more sophisticated it
has internal representations it has
optimizations
that look like and it has another
internal representation then it emits
native code
here you can ask me wait a second why we
could not have it from the get go
just well the reason is we don't have
information to
produce the type specialized irs for the
compiler to do the
good optimizations but if we first
compile with one compiler which uses ics
and then allow it to run then we can
take the state of the ics
which observed all these values and so
on and feed it into the
our complicated compiler as a type
feedback
and then using this time feedback the
information about observed types
we can produce a type specialized ir and
then do
optimizations and emit native code which
is high quality
and with a lot of local redundancies
removed
and that's what crankshaft was and this
whole bump that
we want to quickly repeat in the dart vm
this is the reason behind that bump okay
so uh but you can also spot a couple of
issues here
uh the issue number one is that
you have one compiler that generates
code in one pass from the ast and then
you have the compiler that starts with a
building ir and doing optimizations on
that
and you need to keep them in sync the
building of ir and the one pass compiler
because you also want to switch from
optimize code to unoptimized and
back and the other reason is that
the other problem here is that type
feedback that you try to get from the
ics
you get in a really spooky way because
the
inline caches were for the peak
performance they have the type
information
only in the generated assembly code so
you have to part and match the generated
assembly code
to get the typhoon back out and that's
really spooky
if you patent much the wrong thing then
you get very strange
code out of that it usually works but
sometimes it's a strange performance
okay so darth vm we designed a little
bit differently
you start with a source you get ast okay
everybody's sleeping is worrying part
then you produce one ir for everything
for both for optimizing non-optimizing
compilation
and the only difference is that you
perform optimizations or not perform
optimizations
so there is a single ir single backend
for code generation
and there are additional optimization
passes that you apply once you gathered
enough type information
and another difference is that we did
not have a truly polymorphic ics
from the beginning now it gets more and
more of them soon every pisces will be
truly polymorphic but the dart vm has a
truly polymorphic ics because
they're just tables they collect all the
types that they see
okay so now let's talk about
optimizations this
thing that uh both compilers do but i
will be mostly talking about rtm so it
has a couple of optimizations
i put them all on the slide this couple
some of them are simple some of them a
little bit sophisticated but just
a tiny little bit not more complicated
than baking a
pie so okay strange analogy i don't know
why i say that
uh let's talk about them so one thing we
actually understood while
doing both v8 and rpm is that you don't
usually need a sophisticated
optimizations that you read about
in the papers because they are very
generic they can hit a lot of cases
but you actually want to hit just 80
percent and do it fast
so a lot of our optimizations are just a
single pass over the dominated tree the
dominator tree is
uh is this a structure you can find in
the control flow graph that
tells you if you get to the block
three for example you need to pass
through the block one or if you get to
the block four you need to pass through
block one and block three guaranteed
so you just do a single pass top down or
bottom up whatever
and then you can derive some useful
information from the domination relation
in the tree
here's an example from how we propagate
types
you have a class check and a specialized
load
from a fixed offset from the field of
that class
and somewhere down the graph you have
another block which was not type
specialized for whatever reason
maybe it was not executed so the ics
didn't deliver
type information so you just left the
call there
which is slow but these blocks are
connected with a domination relation so
you walk
top down and propagate the type and you
see
that x is guaranteed to be a because
it's checked
in the block that dominates so you can
just replace this call with a load
and there will be no check because the
check is already done
okay simple so it's a very
simple but very powerful optimization
which is very useful
uh it can do a lot of type
specialization
i wrote it all on the slide but i don't
think it's really
necessary to tell here but one important
part is that for example the dart has
production mode and the check note so
dart is this
a little bit strange language which is
kind of typed
but kind of untyped and dynamically
typed so you can write typed annotations
but they're completely uh unused in the
production mode they just
like comments but if you run in the
checked mode then they are checked but
they're checked in the run time
so they're basically converted to
assertions that some value is of certain
type
in a place where you for example azure
to the variable that is typed as t
you check that the values that you store
is t so if you run in the checked mode
then you have the code full of these
assertions and you really need to do a
good job propagating the types to
eliminate these assertions to bring the
performance penalty down
okay
now i just told you that the type
annotations they are
neglected so you can say uh wait a
second there is
there is a problem here you told us that
the classes they have a fixed shape
okay we can load from a fixed offset but
what we are loading from there we don't
know
because the type annotation on the field
means nothing in the production mode so
you still have to check what you load it
when you want to do an operation on that
yes unfortunately you do so we decided
to do a local optimization there
so yes you know what you're where are
you loading from but you don't know what
you are loading we decided to track
types of the fields globally so each
field has associated
type information which which you track
in the runtime
which tells you i don't know anything
about type or i know that the
all fields in all objects of this type
well
this field in all objects of this type
that exist in the
in the heap container special a
particular class
or it can tell you that they contain
different classes i don't know which one
so it's a very simple three three
element lattice
for well not real but okay yeah so uh
and when you load stuff from this field
you assume that you loaded this
particular class if you know which one
but when you store you have to check so
that's what we use and it allows to
eliminate a lot of the
type checks on the values that you load
and when you store you usually already
know what kind of value you store
so this guard can be eliminated with a
type propagation pass which i was
telling you about
before it's it's useful
okay yes
another optimization that we do is
obviously the unboxing of the primitive
values so the doubles they are
floating in the hip box and the boxes
and we also have cmd values which you
can use the
basically cmd intrinsics to operate on
to speed up your graphics or games or
whatever
and you want to unbox them from these
boxes that float in the heap
and put them on the registers on the
stack in the optimize code
so it's very simple to do in dart
because values are typed integer is a
different type from double
or cmd so you just use inline caches to
tell you this operation was performed on
double so this operation was performed
and simply type
and then you unbox this variables or
values
there is a problem with integers because
integer is a non-fixed precision it's
uh arbitrary width integer so you need
to range profile the
the values that you the operations like
if you added two integers what kind of
range did you get out uh and which
uh which operands did this operation see
so vm does not try to do that yet but
you really need it to perform to perform
well on the
like 64-bit integer arithmetic for
example
okay so it works well for us just using
the type-based unboxing because
uh we have a split between double and
hint unlike javascript where
you really have to do a range profiling
to understand where you want to use
doubles and when you want to specialize
to ins
because the javascript has only double
type
in the language and we also use this
mine coding just like the v8 uses it's
shifted basically with one tag big
one tech beat at the least significant
bit
uh tag representation so
okay yes as i said you the
javascript is a little bit more
convoluted it has uh
only double but bitwise operations that
can carry
this double to in 32 or you in 32 range
and uh you really need to track what's
happening in your
code to understand how to emit the most
inefficient arithmetic
okay
now let's talk a little bit about loads
so the programs are usually
full of loads and stores that's what
they do
and here is an example you do a
load on one path that loads a field
and you do a store in another path and
then both of them flow
into the place where you load again and
there is an obvious redundancy here
like on one path you know that the value
will be the same
like a well if you know that nothing
changes it and on the other path you
know that the
the value will be b because that's what
we stored there so what we do here is
that we replace this
load with the five function the five
function is an artifact of an ssa
representation which
is equal to a on this path and the equal
to b
on this path and the load is
nowhere to be seen so you can just keep
these values in the register
and then there will be no load it's a
very powerful optimization actually
and it's very useful and it's useful
especially
to eliminate the overheads of the
object-oriented or
like high-level abstractions
for example if you do an iteration over
the list
you need an iterator to do the situation
so this code looks
for to vm something like that
it's a lot of code there is an
abstraction you have to allocate
iterator you have to move it and
you have to always ask it what's the
current element
so what we the vm does is uh
it inlines these operations that were
highlighted so you
have an allocation of the iterator then
you initialize the fields
you have like a list stored in the
iterator you have a current index
then you increment the index check it
against the length
that's the move next operation in line
and then you
just take load this element from the
list at this index
okay a lot of operations with the fields
and that's where the load forwarding
kicks in
so first what it did is you can see
it forwarded all the loads of it.list
and there it just uses the list because
it knows that nothing changes this field
it just can use the list the original
one
then it also forwarded some of the
operations with idx with index and
introduced the new
like pentagram local variable
that stores the current iteration count
essentially
and uh it when it loads from the list
it just uses this variable but
it still has to store it in the iterator
every now and again but it knows that it
these two very two things are in sync
like the field in the iterator
and the local variable so it can just
use it when it loads from the list it
doesn't have to read from the iterator
the current index
and what is left is just to remove the
location of the iterator
that's a separate path it can just kill
it and
now we are left with a local variable
and no
sign of iterator so this code is
basically as efficient
as the normal loop success
the last step was not actually a load
forwarding but something called
allocation thinking which removes the
allocation from the optimized code
and puts it on the uncommonly executed
passes like the optimization for example
uh i actually lied to you a little bit
so you need two optimizations are not
enough
to fix this the structure of this loop
because
the iterator looks something like that
it's a lot of code
so to produce a really efficient result
you need to
apply many things together like for
example there is a check
which checks that lengths of the
list does not change to help the
programmers discover the concurrent
modification issues
and to eliminate this check you need to
do constant folding and so on
or like it returns a boolean but
you really want to avoid materializing
this boolean on the stack or in the
register and then check it
whether it's true or false so you have
to instead of the
materializing the boolean you have to
directly connect the control flow
edges when you're in line and so on
there are many passes that
have to work over this code to give you
a efficient
result that as is as efficient as a
normal loop
okay and the same you can do with a
closure
you can completely eliminate the
allocation of the closure for example
and also have the
efficient loop okay so
as you can see there are some
optimizations that are really important
to eliminate the overhead of the
abstractions
and the last thing that i really want to
tell you about is that
all these optimizations they're really
highly dependent on the inlining which
is i think the hardest problem
of the compiler construction actually
so the problem with inlining is that
to understand whether you will benefit
from the inline in or not
you need to try but at the same time
trying costs you so if you have a
compiler that has to produce the code
relatively quickly and it doesn't have
all the time in the universe to think
about it
you have a trouble because if you don't
in line for example in the
previous example where you need to
inline
constructor to see that how the fields
are changed or in line move next to see
how they changed when you move to the
next element and so on
you can do no optimizations you will be
stuck with the iterator which costs you
but at the same time you cannot try to
inline everything and then undo what you
tried if you
see no benefit because you will spend
incredible amount of time compiling
that's a problem with no clear solution
so you have to be really conservative
you
use very brain dead heuristics well some
of them are not brain dead
some of them are too brainy but doesn't
work
yeah as i said the inline is the most
important thing
kind of uh so the solution
is uh you have well at least the
solution that we adopted for now is that
the library is kind of white listed to
force in lining
of iterators and so on to force the
elimination of the abstractions
and you use some spooky heuristics to uh
help user code a little bit but if it
doesn't hit it you have no way of fixing
it because language doesn't allow you to
control the jit compiler
no clear solution that's the problem
okay and i think that would be it
thank you very much for attention